bien chers collègues au terme de 6 66
auditions nous recevons aujourd'hui les
représentants de la société uber
principaux concernés par les sujets
traités par notre commission enquête
l'audition d'aujourd'hui se déroulera en
deux temps tout d'abord nous entendrons
monsieur Dara costereau Chahi président
directeur général du groupe uber que je
remercie de cette rendue disponible en
visioconférence et qu'il aura ne quitter
à 16h30 puis nous poursuivrons la
discussion avec Monsieur en Dubaï
directeur des affaires publiques monte
chez uber et Monsieur Pierre Dimitri
gorkoti ancien directeur Europe de
l'Ouest et uber président duburitz
depuis mars 2020 messieurs je vous
remercie également nous avoir rejoint à
Paris pour répondre aux commissions de
aux questions de notre commission je
vous souhaite la bienvenue comme vous le
savez à la suite des révélations du
consortium international des
journalistes d'investigations ce qui est
désormais convenu d'appeler les uber
files et qui ont dénoncé des méthodes
d'implantation et de lobbying agressif
du beurre en France l'Assemblée
nationale a créé fin janvier 2023 une
commission d'enquête c'est si poursuivre
double objet d'une part identifié
l'ensemble des actions de lobbying
menées par la société uber pour pouvoir
s'implanter en France le rôle les
décideurs publics de l'époque
je serai intéressé aussi puisque je
crois que vous avez été interrogé en
tout cas vos représentants dans d'autres
commissions d'enquête parlementaires en
Europe sur la permanence ou non de
pratique qui ont été révélées par les
uberfall je pense notamment par exemple
l'utilisation du du kill switch pour
faire disparaître des documents ou les
liens entre une filiale et les
head corters de
uber en Californie enfin nous
interrogeons aussi pour aller sur la
période actuelle sur le modèle
économique de votre entreprise qui se
fait or ne dégage toujours pas de profit
en France dans le secteur du transport
public de personnes comme ça dans celui
de la livraison quelles sont vos
perspectives à court et moyen terme et
dans quelle mesure le statut
d'indépendant ou de salariés des
travailleurs de vos plateformes de VTC
ou de livraison
un flux sur la rentabilité et le modèle
économique de votre entreprise nous
aurons certainement d'autres questions à
vous poser ainsi qu'à vos collègues mais
je vous propose d'entamer nos
discussions à ce stade je rappelle que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
qu'elle est retransmise en direct sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale avant de
vous laisser la parole je vous rappelle
que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité monsieur costereau Chailly
pardon je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre micro
je vous remercie je vous laisse la
parole
je suis le président général de Hubert
j'ai commencé en 2017 après quelques
mois de crise sur la culture de notre
entreprise nos pratiques et notre nos
dirigeants cela a mené à beaucoup
d'examens publics
beaucoup d'enquêtes de gouvernement
et la démission de plusieurs cadres il y
a eu des erreurs dans le passé il y a
même eu une série télévisée à ce sujet
aujourd'hui je m'adresse à cette
commission
parlementaire après toutes ces crises je
ne suis pas ici pour défendre les
erreurs du passé
on m'a demandé de venir dans
l'entreprise pour presque tout changer
dans l'entreprise on a changé les
valeurs de l'entreprise on a établi une
gouvernance stricte
la sécurité était la plus grande
priorité de notre entreprise Hubert est
tout à fait différente aujourd'hui 90%
des employés aujourd'hui nous aurons
joint après la crise de 2017 et si c'est
employés sont toujours ici c'est que ils
ont vu que nous avions des nouvelles
règles des nouvelles perspectives
aujourd'hui
nous faisons partie intégrante de
millions de personnes autour du monde
nous sommes passés d'une R2
confrontation à une aire de
collaboration nous avons une volonté de
trouver des accords avec nos opposants
et de travailler avec les syndicats et
les
taxis nous avons plus de 10000 branches
autour du monde des millions beaucoup
d'employés
nous avons amélioré la manière dont nos
produits fonctionnent tout d'abord nous
écoutons nos clients et également leur
retour
nous valorisons la flexible les clients
valorisent notre flexibilité mais
nos employés veulent aussi de la
protection sociale nous avons signé des
accords récemment ici en France et cela
représente un procès et nous montre que
nous voulons travailler de manière
légale
tous les retours que nous écoutons sont
importants pour nous
il y a plus de 6 millions de personnes
qui nous utilisent autour du monde en
Europe et également et nous sommes un
des plus gros employeurs au monde
ces derniers trimestres
nous avons
fait 13 % de bénéfices de plus que
l'année dernière 13,7 millions de
dollars milliards de dollars
et nous sommes responsables c'est
toujours un objectif pour nous
[Musique]
pour et nous voulons aider tous ceux qui
sont qui ont été laissés de côté tous
ceux qui veulent une deuxième chance
nous voulons travailler avec les
gouvernements
afin de nous assurer que
les occasions que nous leur fournissons
sont tout à fait légales et offre une
protection
nous voulons également être une
entreprise durable c'est au cœur de nos
objectifs
voulons être un complément au transport
qui existe déjà et nous voulons que les
villes européennes deviennent plus
vertes nous sommes ici également pour
aider les villes quand on a besoin par
exemple pendant la pandémie
par exemple
nos employés ont aidés pendant la
pandémie les travailleurs essentiels à
se rencontrer au travail
nous accompagnons également de manière
gratuite les réfugiés dans le monde
entier
et nous aidons également la livraison de
produits de base
d'ailleurs c'est en France que vers
cette emprunté en premier en 2008 et
nous cherchons à lier les communautés
entre elles mais cela ne sera un succès
que si les villes s'épanouissent et nous
voulons améliorer notre plateforme nous
n'arrêter ons jamais de vouloir
améliorer notre plateforme cela fait
longtemps que nous travaillons nous
allons encore avoir beaucoup de travail
mais nous sommes déterminés à regagner
votre confiance je suis fier de mon
entreprise aujourd'hui et je vous
demande de nous juger sur ce que nous
avons fait c'est six dernières années et
ce que nous ferons dans les années à
venir merci
bonjour monsieur le PDG
monsieur Cochereau Chailly je souhaite
vous poser une question au sujet du
better deal que vous avez
réalisé et j'ai relu avec attention
l'article sponsorisé qui date de février
2021 une meilleure offre pour les
travailleurs des plateformes européennes
dans ce document vous défendez votre
stratégie au niveau du Berre qui est
finalement d'encourager un meilleur
dialogue entre les plateformes et les
travailleurs et à cet effet vous notez
que certains pays auront européens
montrent déjà la voie et vous citez la
France la France a achevé une série de
réformes progressives augmentant le
niveau de transparence et de choix que
les plateformes devraient offrir au
travailleur tout en garantissant des
protections telles que l'assurance
obligatoire et la formation
professionnelle et du coup
votre stratégie en fait qui vise à
promouvoir un dialogue social
entre les plateformes les États et les
travailleurs m'amène à vous demander ce
que vous pensez finalement quel est
votre analyse de la politique française
de la création de l'art en avril 2021
l'autorité des relations sociales des
plateformes d'emploi jusqu'à la position
de la France assez éloignée voire opposé
à la directive européenne de présomption
de salariat et quel est votre position
par rapport à cette directive européenne
de présomption de salariat qui en ce
moment en débat
que nous respectons toutes les
réglementations toutes les lois nous
croyons
car nous écoutons nos employés
nous pensons qu'il valorise la
flexibilité avant tout la flexibilité de
travailler quand il le veulent la
flexibilité de travailler où il le
veulent selon leur propre terme et la
flexibilité de choisir une plateforme
sur laquelle ils peuvent travailler une
plateforme le matin une autre peut-être
le soir
nous croyons pas que leur flexibilité
devrait se faire au coût de la
protection sociale
et au coût de leur représentation
sociale la position donc que nous
la proposition qu'il a d'autres reflète
les souhaits des travailleurs sur la
plateforme à la fois en France et dans
le monde entier donc cette flexibilité
de décider quand vous travaillez combien
vous allez gagner mais avec toujours une
protection sociale
donc un salaire minimum
un dialogue social par exemple en France
qui résulte directement à une course
minime le prix minime d'une course
et donc ça c'était le résultat d'un
dialogue social
le résultat d'un compromis
le résultat de discussion que nous avons
eu ensemble nous pensons donc qu'il peut
y avoir une solution qui est bénéfique
pour tous Lorsque j'ai rejoint
l'entreprise ces protections n'étaient
pas en place en tant qu'entreprise nous
ne sommes adaptés parce que il était
nécessaire de le faire nous avons écouté
les gouvernements
les régulateurs et très franchement
si le fait de mettre en place ces
protections
fait qu'il est de venir travailler chez
uber
pour quelqu'un qui range qui rejoint la
plateforme qui comprend que la
flexibilité est au cœur de nos
préoccupations mais qu'il y a une
protection sociale alors cette personne
saura quels sont les attentes de
l'entreprise et quel sera représentée au
sein de l'entreprise nous pensons que
c'est la bonne marche à suivre et nous
espérons que le Parlement de l'Union
européenne
écoutera les souhaits des travailleurs
des conducteurs qui veulent à la fois
être leur propre patron avoir de la
flexibilité et être protégé
alors j'aurais souhaité que vous soyez
un peu plus précis du coup que
pensez-vous de la création de l'ARPE en
France c'est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de cette création de
l'autorité des relations sociales des
plateformes d'emplois et quel est votre
position à la fois sur la directive
présomption de salariat tels que
préconisés par le Parlement européen et
la Commission européenne et que
pensez-vous de la position de la France
qui a priori n'est pas favorable à cette
directive de présomption de salariat
de ce nouveau cadre de dialogue social
est une bonne nouvelle ce dialogue est
nécessaire
aujourd'hui et le sera toujours à
l'avenir
pour les évolutions futures de notre
notre modèle économique à l'avenir nos
relations avec les entreprises avec les
gouvernements etc donc c'est positif
nous continuerons à nous engager dans ce
dialogue social quant à la directive
européenne pour la présomption
de salariat et bien nous pensons qu'à
l'ignore tout à fait qu'elle fait fi des
souhaits des travailleurs et parfois je
me demande
si les personnes qui l'ont créé
cette directive ont réellement écouté
les travailleurs des plateformes parce
que la seule chose que l'on retient de
toutes ces conversations c'est que
l'indépendance est au cœur des valeurs
de ces travailleurs elle peut créer des
incertitudes cette présomption peut
créer des incertitudes
une situation précaire elle peut liée à
des centaines de milliers de personnes
au chômage en Europe et ce n'est pas
qu'une théorie
c'est tout à fait réel par exemple la
Genève
où les conducteurs de transport sont des
employés
60 70 % des travailleurs ont perdu cette
occasion de travail donc des milliers de
personnes se sont retrouvés au chômage
les taux de salaire ne sont pas
améliorés les prix augmenté pour les
consommateurs
la couverture
a diminué pour les petites villes et
parmi certaines communautés également
finalement le résultat est tout à fait
négatif encore une fois je ne parle pas
de théorie d'études c'est le la vraie
vie si je puis dire le vrai monde dont
nous parlons aujourd'hui donc je pense
que à l'avenir
il faut dire que la France n'est pas
seule à vouloir améliorer sa directive
sa directive ne reflète pas selon moi
les besoins et les souhaits des
travailleurs aujourd'hui il nous faut
nous concentrer sur la manière dont nous
pouvons améliorer les conditions de
travail des travailleurs et améliorer
effectivement leur flexibilité leur
indépendance
alors Monsieur cocher
on peut donc en conclure que à la
lecture de votre tribune et du better
deal qui était donc défendu par votre
plateforme
d'ailleurs avant la création
en France de l'art votre stratégie qui
est de défendre un dialogue social et
des droits des travailleurs permettait
aussi pour vous avec vos mots de
respecter la flexibilité et le souhait
d'indépendance des travailleurs pour mes
mots cela permettait aussi et c'est une
stratégie qui permet à Hubert de pouvoir
montrer qu'il concède un dialogue social
et des droits sociaux mais en échappant
à toute qualification en salariés et je
constate que c'est exactement la
stratégie qui a pu suivre le
gouvernement français ainsi le
gouvernement précédent sur sur les deux
précédentes mandatures et que vous
retrouvez finalement la même position
que le gouvernement français vis-à-vis
de la directive je voudrais néanmoins
vous vous préciser
ce que le président de la Chambre
sociale de la Cour de cassation a pu
dire lors de lors de son audition
concernant en fait la question en fait
du salariat du lien de subordination qui
peut répondre à cette question
du souhait d'indépendance comme vous le
dites des de certains travailleurs il
disait l'existence d'une relation de
travail salarié ne dépend ni de la
volonté exprimée par les parties ni de
la dénomination que celle-ci ont donné à
leur convention mais des conditions de
fait dans lesquelles est exercée
l'activité professionnelle entre
d’autres termes peu importe que le
contraste était signé ou non qu'il soit
qualifié ou pas de contrat de travail il
appartient toujours au juge de vérifier
dans les fesses il y a un lien de
subordination écarte caractérisé en
clair dans notre droit français droit du
travail
ça n'est pas le travailleur qui choisit
d'être indépendant ou d'être salarié
c'est de fait
les conditions de sa subordination qui
déterminent si en fait il faut
absolument un contrat de travail salarié
parce que manifestement il est dans un
rapport de subordination et le chauffeur
VTC ne fixe pas le tarif des courses
vous avez dit qu'il était libre de
travailler quand il voulait comment il
voulait mais en fait de fait il est dans
une telle précarité paupérisation du
fait de de la baisse régulière du tarif
des courses et de l'augmentation
régulière de la contribution que prend
uber qu'il est obligé de travailler de
manière dans une amplitude horaire par
jour par semaine et par mois et sur
l'année extrêmement forte avec une perte
de de liberté et avec aussi cette
problématique de la déconnexion
quand la quand la plateforme le décide
et son droit véritablement de regard
donc
est-ce que vous comprenez qu'en fait il
y a la manifestement un désaccord
complet entre cette orientation là que
vous défendez et la réalité du droit du
code du travail et finalement est-ce que
le projet
engagé par Hubert et suivi par plein
d'autres plateformes et que certains ont
parlé du bérisations pourrait aussi
l'appeler capitalisme de plateforme vise
depuis le début
à contourner de fait à échapper au code
du travail à faire croire qu'on est dans
une relation mise en relation d'un tram
de travailleur indépendant et d'une
clientèle pour un service alors qu'en
fait nous sommes sur des faux
indépendants et finalement soit un
travail soit un problème face à une
problématique de travail dissimulé ou de
près ici de main d'oeuvre
juridique français et alors nous parlons
stabiliser d'ailleurs beaucoup de
tribunaux en France ont
précisément
tranché en faveur de l'indépendance je
pense que votre présentation des
travailleurs comme étant subordonnés ne
reflètent pas les faits sur le terrain
le fait est que notre plateforme
est une plateforme que nos coursiers et
chauffeurs choisissent d'utiliser ou
choisir de ne pas utiliser de fait leur
responsable de leur propre
travail sur leur propre ils sont
responsables eux-mêmes ils peuvent
décider de viser la plateforme si elle
répond à leurs besoins en matière
également de protection sociale de
recettes et y compris l'accident
l'assurance accident que nous offrons
par notre mise de partenaires également
nous pensons qu'il s'agit d'un cadre
équilibré d'une relation équilibrée
entre la société et les travailleurs qui
choisissent de travailler en utilisant
notre plateforme donc vous savez je ne
suis pas expert juridique sur le terrain
nous avons toujours eu pour l'intention
de respecter la loi
nous prenons pas un dialogue social avec
les coursiers et les chauffeurs et ce
dialogue social
n'est pas lié à des questions de
d'obligation juridique mais il vise à
établir un cadre équilibré dans le cadre
duquel les coursiers les chauffeurs
peuvent continuer de disposer de cette
marge de manœuvre ça souplesse cette
indépendance tout en jouissant
d'indépendant d'assurance et de
protection également je me permettrai de
répéter
à chaque fois que nous espérons que vous
serez à l'écoute des souhaits et des
coursiers des chauffeurs à savoir qui
nous ont dit à répétition qu'ils ne
souhaitent pas être employé il ne veut
pas de verbe choisir entre une
protection et des prestations et la
souplesse qu'il valorise
les travailleurs des plateformes qui
sont
représentées dans dans l'arbre pour
certains pour ceux qui défendent
l'indépendance le statut d'indépendant
en fait ont exprimé lors des auditions
auprès de la commission d'enquête
parlementaires qu'ils souhaitait pour
être enfin respecter comme vrais
indépendants fixer eux-mêmes leurs
tarifs
et prendre part pleinement à l'ensemble
de la partage à l'ensemble du partage de
la valeur que dites-vous de cela pour
eux ce sont deux critères importants
pour que leur statut d’indépendance soit
réellement respectée première chose
deuxième chose je réinsiste sur le droit
français qui date depuis 1910 et qui a
été conclu conquis de haute-lutz il
estime que quand les liens de
subordination sont avérés il doit y
avoir un contrat de travail si une
plateforme y échappe pourquoi d'autres
entreprises ne feraient pas de même et à
ce moment-là c'est l'ensemble du code du
travail et l'ensemble du salariat qui
est remis en cause comprenez que cela
pour nous est absolument impossible et
que la perspective de la directive
européenne présomption de salariat est
au contraire en fait la réaffirmation de
notre État de droit d'où l'enjeu pour
nous de se débat là et le désaccord que
nous avons en ce moment et qui nous
amène à souhaiter que il puisse y avoir
un débat à l'Assemblée nationale assorti
d'un vote pour définir la position de la
France définit mais là cela va au-delà
de vos prérogatives
des plateformes le fait que les
coursiers et les chauffeurs
prennent par la croissance de la
plateforme si l'on prend par exemple les
croissants de la du dernier trimestre il
y a eu une croissance de 33% de la
société
et c'est l'envoi les recettes des
coursiers des chauffeurs ce dernier
trimestre sur la plateforme il y a eu
quelques 13 milliards
d'engrangés avec une croissance de
quelques 30% annuellement c'est un
rythme plus rapide que la croissance de
l'entreprise d'un point de vue
mathématique c'est donc dire que les
coursiers et les chauffeurs
voient leurs recettes croître plus
rapidement sur la plateforme et la
plateforme elle-même
ma fiche une croissance donc l'idée
cuber
prenne une part plus importante et il
faut d'un point de vue mathématique
nous devons livrer concurrence tous les
jours
pour
le temps et l'attention des chauffeurs
et des coursiers
et cela c'est le propre d'un marché
concurrentiel et en même temps la
plateforme maintient une indépendance
tout en fournissant des recettes très
solides
ainsi qu'une protection sociale qui
continue de se renforcer et continueront
de se renforcer à mesure que nous
prenons pas un dialogue social avec les
représentants des chauffeurs des
coursiers encore une fois je vous dirais
que
cela relève du droit français beaucoup
de tribunaux français ont tranché en
faveur de la dépendance je crois que
c'est aucun débat qui se poursuit et
nous continuerons de rester à l'écoute
des sous et des chauffeurs et des
coursiers
pour une dernière question
allez-y allez-y pose vos questions
bonjour monsieur vous j'ai trois
questions en fait première question vous
avez dit nous ne voulons pas que les
villes robes nous voulons pardon nous
voulons au contraire que les villes
européennes soient plus vertes alors
pensez-vous que justement l'existence de
ces plateformes
préserve le
la nature et ne contribue pas au
contraire à davantage de pollution
puisque il faut livrer
voilà première question deuxième
question donc sur le fait que vous
pensez que que vous l'aidez plus vertes
deuxième question nous accompagnons de
manière gratuite il me semble que vous
avez dit vous allez me reprendre si
c'est pas ça les migrants
ou les personnes vous allez me préciser
le mot parce que je l'ai oublié le mot
que vous avez employé exactement nous
accompagnons de manière gratuite donc je
voulais vous préciser pourquoi vous avez
dit cela quel rapport en fait avec
uber
quelle est la philosophie qu'est-ce que
voilà j'ai pas bien compris je voudrais
que vous me préciser ça
et troisième question vous parlez de
choix vous dites que les indépendants
choisissent d'être sur une plateforme
mais en même temps vous avez dit que la
création de ces plateformes était utile
justement pour les gens qui étaient au
chômage et pensez-vous donc que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui est le choix
surtout quand ils sont chômage ou
surtout quand ils sont en situation
irrégulière moi pour ma part je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas de choix et je pense
que ça peut tirer si vous voulez les
salaires vers le bas et c'est en ce sens
que certains sont inquiets effectivement
et voudraient peut-être le statut de
la protection en fait du droit du
travail parce que
[Musique]
parce que en fait
ces gens la plupart des gens qui
soi-disant sont indépendants sur uber ne
le sont pas tant que ça
et est-ce que ça ne crée pas enfin une
concurrence déloyale avec les
entreprises classiques qui ont leur
chaise en France
alors je peux répéter pour la
traductrice parce que c'est un métier
difficile je sais je peux répéter pour
la traductrice si elle le souhaite ou le
traducteur l'intérêt voilà
me répéter la deuxième question on
demande monsieur s'agissant des migrants
la question c'est pas très clair et
exactement mais j'ai noté nous
accompagnons de manière gratuite et il
me semble de mémoire que c'était les
migrants ou des personnes en situation
régulière j'ai loupé le monde donc ça on
peut me le préciser si quelqu'un a mieux
entendu que moi nous accompagnons de
matière gratuite ça m'a fait tilte et je
me suis dit il faut que j'interroge sur
cela parce que j'ai pas bien compris
votre philosophie ou ce qu'il y avait
derrière ce que vous vouliez dire en
quelque sorte
et pourquoi ça fait partie de vos
objectifs
gratuits souvent je comprends pas ton
de vos questions madame il s'agissant de
la pollution
et la congestion du trafic bon les gens
continueront de déplacer
il y aura des endroits qui nécessiteront
cette transport qui il y aura toujours
une demande en transport
et une augmentation de ta demande en
transport dans des économies saines de
Parlement nous ce que nous avons
déterminé c'est que nous voulons être
absolument chef de fil en matière
d'électrification de des flottes de
transport et la plateforme la plus
propre sur Terre en matière de transport
à la demande et pour cela il faut
consentir des investissements en
conséquent et il faut également tisser
des partenariats avec les
administrations locales avec d'autres
entreprises privées qui tentent
de réaliser une croissance durable et un
avenir durable aux États-Unis et en
Europe nous avons réussi à mener notre
activité sans émission et notre flotte
soit entièrement électrique d'ici 2030
et qu'il n'est plus
des missions d'ici 2040 partout dans le
monde alors c'est encore une transition
à l'étape embryonnaire si on pense un
chauffeur uber qui conduit beaucoup plus
de kilomètres qu'un conducteur moyen les
conducteurs de duber sont les premiers
qui devraient passer des voitures
alimentées au diesel à des voitures
électroniques l'incidence sur
l'environnement sera extrêmement
importante nous nous sommes engagés à
investir plus de 800 millions de dollars
de notre propre poche
de partenariat pour pouvoir accompagner
cette transition cela fait intervenir
par exemple la réduction de nos
commissions sur les les courses en
voiture électrique de sorte que le
coursier ou le chauffeur jouit d'un site
incitatif économique pour acheter un
véhicule électrique en plus des
subventions existantes nous voulons donc
jouer notre part à cet égard une
initiative très importante pour nous
c'est les le gaspillage alimentaire et
Hubert eat et chef de fil en matière de
lutte contre ce fléau nous travaillons
avec des restaurants locaux notamment
pour les aider à faire l'achat à rabais
d'emballage durable et d'étiqueter les
emballages durables pour que les
consommateurs qui veulent jouer leur
et apporter leur pierre l'édifice
peuvent consommer d'aliments d'endroit
qui ont des emballages durables
également donc nous avons toujours été
devant toujours fait preuve l'esprit
d'équipe nous sommes chefs de films nous
adorons sur cette transition il y aura
toujours des besoins en demande et des
demandes en livraison et en transport
mais nous voulons que la demande se
reflète sur le marché par l'utilisation
de voiture claire proche ou électrique
et avec des emballages durables et nous
serons tout à fait présents à cet égard
cela vient avec des coups certes mais il
en va de notre responsabilité envers le
monde et envers les villes où nous
travaillons et nous pensons que cela
profite à notre entreprise également
lorsqu'elle entreprise
lorsque un consommateur dit je vois que
Hubert et Hubert gris ou Hubert vert il
peut se dire
qu'il soit pris une bonne idée en
Californie aujourd'hui il y a tout un
pan de kilomètres qui sont des avis par
des véhicules électriques il y a
quelques 15 kilomètres à Londres qui
sont également des services par ces
véhicules électriques donc il y a encore
beaucoup de
d'amélioration pour être écologique vous
avez parlé des réfugiés donc je passe au
deuxième sujet qui est donc beaucoup
plus sérieux
alors c'est une activité que nous avons
piloté en Ukraine comme vous le savez
nous tenons solidaire de l'Ukraine dans
le présent en Ukraine et à qui est
notamment et une fois que la guerre est
survenue pour la sécurité de nos
employés nous avons arrêté nos activités
à certaines membres de nos activités
sont arrivés en Pologne mais les
gouvernements les villes en Ukraine
zombie qu'ils avaient besoin de notre
aide et d'un réseau de transport donc de
fait nous avons relancé nos activités en
Ukraine nous avons élargi le nombre de
vie nous exploitons notre flotte et dans
le cadre de nos activités nous offrons
un transport gratuit à l'intention des
réfugiés qui quittent l'Ukraine et qui
ont besoin d'un transport donc ce n'est
pas une entreprise rentable certes mais
il en va de la récepté de notre
entreprise que d'être sur le terrain
nous sommes très différents d'autres
entreprises technologiques
en ce sens que nous avons beaucoup de
codeurs
dans le monde virtuel nous avons aussi
une des personnes sur le terrain
concrètement dans les villes où nous
travaillons et nous sommes présents
c'est donc quand une ville a des besoins
et les besoins sont criant en Ukraine
nous sommes présents c'est implique de
transporter gratuitement des réfugiés de
cela signifie qu'il faut une version
différente de lumière pour qu'on puisse
tenir compte des
particularités culturelles
du pays et donc pour auto 3ème question
alors oui effectivement il s'agissait
pardon donc je pense pour votre
troisième question
c'est tout à fait
pertinent cette troisième question
quelqu’un qui est au chômage qui a
besoin de travail et de protection
certes l'autre plateforme
est une plateforme
qui représente un choix très
fort très clair pour les personnes ont
besoin de travail une plateforme très
souple qui me permet de travailler avec
la personne quand vous le voulez ou vous
voulez et sont les modalités que vous
souhaitez
le fait que notre plateforme est très
concurrencée avec les autres plateformes
sur le marché vous avez le choix entre
avoir un emploi à temps plein ou
travailler sur une plateforme ou
travailler sur une plateforme rivale des
livres ou d'autres ce sont là des choix
qui s'offrent aux travailleurs et nous
souhaitons être une plateforme qui
permet aux travailleurs d'avoir une
certaine souplesse avec la plateforme
tout en bénéficiant de protection et de
droits et nous souhaitons vivre en
poursuivre le dialogue social pour nos
veiller à ce que c'est droit et ces
protections continuent d'évoluer de se
renforcer parce qu'encore une fois cela
permettra d'attirer davantage de
coursier de chauffeurs vers la
plateforme Hubert
mais c'est en réalité une question de
société et une personne qui est au
chômage qui est dans une place difficile
par rapport à la société cette personne
devrait avoir différents choix devrait
avoir différentes agences et de faire
avoir la possibilité de choisir en fait
le pouvoir de choisir ce qu'ils veulent
faire à l'avenir nous pensons que notre
plateforme fait partie de ses choix
c'est un choix sur et il est très
important pour nous de nous assurer que
la documentation est en place que les
processus d'identification sont en place
que notre prof plateforme et sécurisé à
la fois pour les clients mais également
pour les chauffeurs l'identité de chacun
est vérifiée tout l'historique de chacun
les statuts d'immigration par exemple
sont vérifiées voilà ce que nous voulons
assurer
nous voulons aider les gens qui parfois
ont passe par des moments difficiles je
suis désolé
je sais que vous avez encore beaucoup de
questions
sur la France de manière plus spécifique
je dois partir mais
j'aimerais que Pierre Dimitri et enjeu
qui sont ici j'aimerais leur laisser la
parole ils répondront à toutes les
questions que vous pourriez avoir je
vous remercie énormément pour cette
occasion de contribuer à votre travail
merci est-ce qu'il est possible juste
une petite question très rapide s'il
vous plaît nous avons appris par voie de
presse hier que Hubert technologync va
proposer des voitures sans chauffeur sur
sa plateforme de covoiturage et de
livraison de nourriture notamment à
Phoenix en Arizona est-ce que du coup ce
modèle de voiture sans chauffeur ne va
pas remettre en cause ce que vous dites
du modèle Hubert qui permet le choix de
travailler sous statut indépendant et de
sortir du chômage
c'est une bonne question
nous ne devons nous ne développons pas
de technologie c'est une un partenariat
avec WeMo oui
nous travaillons avec des écosystèmes
très complets nous travaillons avec des
chauffeurs avec des flottes de véhicules
avec des agences de location de
véhicules
par exemple nous travaillons également
avec des agences qui développent des
véhicules autonomes tant que le véhicule
est sécurisé que le service est sécurisé
en réalité notre intérêt dans la
technologie est grand la technologie se
développe très rapidement mais à la fois
c'est tout ça est très lointain
cela ne va pas devenir une partie
intégrante de notre service de sitôt il
s'agissait d'un partenariat c'est une
technologie que nous testons si vous me
demandez si vous me posez la question
est-ce que dans 10 ans il y aura plus ou
moins de coursiers et de chauffeur
je pense qu'il y en aura beaucoup plus
en fait beaucoup plus de conducteurs
humains
merci encore pour cette
occasion de m'avoir laissé m'exprimer
nous allons reprendre merci est-ce que
on doit suspendre non on peut enchaîner
directement voilà très bien chers
collègue nous reprenons le cours de
notre audition des représentants du
groupe uber avec Monsieur en Dubaï
direct avec du groupe uber et puis à
Dimitri gorcoty ancien directeur Europe
de l'Ouest c'était uber et actuelle
directeur du buritz vous étiez tous deux
dirigeants de la société uber entre 2013
et 2017 correspondant à la période
décrite par les uber-files de sorte que
votre audition nous est paru
indispensable compte tenu de l'ensemble
des auditions nous avons conduites et
donc vous avez sûrement eu connaissance
grâce au compte-rendu en ligne et à la
retransmission en différé nous avons
beaucoup de questions à vous poser nous
avons donc envoyé un questionnaire en
amont de cette audition pour vous
permettre de vous y préparer et je vous
remercie pour les réponses que vous nous
avez déjà apporté je précise que le
garde des sceaux m'a informé par
courrier du 9 mai 2023 d'une procédure
judiciaire en cours engagée à l'encontre
de Monsieur Pierre dimitrior Coty dont
je ne connais pas l'objet aussi en
raison du principe de séparation des
pouvoirs législatifs et judiciaires je
remercie d'avance monsieur gorecoty nous
le cas échéant s'il ne peut répondre à
certaines de nos questions en raison de
cette procédure de façon liminaire de
quelle manière qualifierez-vous les
méthodes de lobbying et l'implantation
de la société uber en France entre 2013
et 2017 révélée par Les hubert-féles
quels ont été vous vos réactions au
uber-files pouvez-vous nous préciser le
type d'échange que vous avez eu durant
cette période avec les pouvoirs publics
les décisions que vous avez essayées de
promouvoir ou les évolutions du cadre
législatif ou réglementaire et nous n'en
parlez avec votre ancien collègue
monsieur Coop nous allons parler aussi
parler avec Marc Magan quel regard
portiez-vous sur le cadre réglementaire
législatif français à l'égard des VTC de
votre profession de votre entreprise en
2017 à la fin de la période couverte par
les warface ma question s'inscrit
notamment dans la continuité du propos
de Monsieur Magan qui après avoir
répondre à ses premières questions en
quelques minutes je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité messieurs je vais donc
vous inviter l'un après l'autre à
activer votre micro levez la main droite
et dire je le jure
je jure
soit merci beaucoup je vous laisse la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
députés j'ai rejoint Hubert au début de
ma carrière il y a plus de 10 ans
convaincu l'impact positif
convaincu de l'impact positif que la
technologie notamment le smartphone
pouvait avoir sur la mobilité
géographique et économique de millions
de personnes à travers le monde cette
conviction motive toujours mon
engagement aujourd'hui
comme je l'ai dit publiquement je
regrette certaines des méthodes
utilisées à l'époque pour installer
d'autres modèles le secteur des taxis
n'avait jamais connu d'ouverture et a
réagi avec violence Hubert et parfois
passer en force
j'en ai personnellement subi les
conséquences le procès pénal dont je
fais l'objet en France et le de mes plus
grandes épreuves et certainement aussi
mon plus grand apprentissage
comme notre CIO l'a exprimé en
introduction nous avons clairement
reconnu les erreurs du passé ces erreurs
ont fait l'objet de nombreux de nombreux
articles bien avant la publication des
hubert-files et nous ne les contestons
pas mais Hubert a changé radicalement
depuis l'arrivée de darachoshai à la
tête de l'entreprise fin 2017 nous
sommes passés d'une aire de
confrontation à une aire de dialogue
nous avons bâti des terrains d'entente
et de collaboration avec les pouvoirs
publics et avec l'ensemble des acteurs
du secteur
comme vous je lis la presse la presse je
vois les critiques qui s'expriment à
l'égard de nos activités et j'aimerais
profiter de ce bref propos pour vous
réitérer aussi clairement que possible
que notre priorité ma priorité est bâtir
une activité pérenne apaisée et qui
s'inscrit pleinement dans le tissu
socio-économique européen ma priorité
d'offrir des opportunités attractives
aux travailleurs des services de qualité
aux consommateurs et pour tous plus de
protection et de sécurité
en France tout particulièrement nous
sommes déterminés à avancer dans la voie
du dialogue social avec les partenaires
sociaux pour continuer à améliorer les
conditions d'activité des chauffeurs et
livreurs peu importe l'application
qu'ils utilisent nous investissons aussi
massivement dans les outils
technologiques de pointe pour lutter
contre la fraude en parallèle nous
testons plusieurs programmes d'insertion
pour jouer pleinement notre rôle de
tremplin social dans les territoires
enfin notre taille signifie que nous
pouvons jouer un rôle important dans
l'accélération de la transition
énergétique de tout le secteur la
décoration est désormais l'une de mes
grandes priorités stratégiques à nouveau
je ne chercherai pas à justifier des
comportements passés qui ne sont pas
conformes à nos valeurs actuelles
d'entreprises je suis reconnaissant
d'avoir pu jouer un rôle dans la
transformation de l'entreprise fier du
chemin du chemin parcouru et conscient
qu'il reste encore beaucoup à accomplir
je me tiens à votre disposition je ferai
de mon mieux pour répondre à vos
questions dans le cadre de ce que mes
responsabilités de vice-président en
charge de l'activité livraison au niveau
monde m'amène à suivre et avec le
soutien dans 10 burn pour la partie VTC
merci
bien on aura comme je vous l'ai dit il y
a deux volets de questions je pense un
sur à la fois les uber fail c'est les
livraisons si on permettait de poser
quelques questions sur la question de la
livraison est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter les activités de d'Uber eats
en France le nombre de livreurs
partenaires le nombre de livraisons
auxquelles vous vous livrez vous
permettez une pétition
moyenne par jour ou par an et le revenu
moyen de vos livreurs
oui bien sûr alors je précise que
certaines de ces informations ont été
fournies en amont mais je les ai devant
les yeux et je suis ravi de de les
présenter peut-être pour vous donner une
idée dans un premier temps de où en est
uber eats en France et à travers le
monde
aujourd'hui en France
uber eats est une activité une
application qui est utilisée par près de
65000 coursiers qui utilisent
l'application
c'est une application qui a été
téléchargée près de 18 millions de fois
et je dirais qui se caractérise par un
ancrage local très fort
laissez-moi vous donner quelques
exemples nous opérons dans 340
agglomérations à travers le à travers le
pays dans des agglomérations de moins de
10000 habitants nous avons noué des
partenariats avec près de 45000
restaurants et commerciaux commerçants
pardon qui pour 70% d'entre eux sont des
indépendants
nous avons également jouons nous jouons
un rôle de premier plan dans le avec
notre partenariat et notre sponsoring de
l'équipe de France de football et nous
avons évidemment des équipes locales pas
simplement à Paris mais à travers la
France qui soutiennent encourage et
travail avec les différents partenaires
que nous avons donc je dirais un ancrage
local qui est très fort nous sortons
évidemment de la pandémie et je me
permets de d'ajouter
l'impact important que la livraison au
sens plus large et uber eats ont pu
avoir pendant cette pandémie à peu près
5000 restaurants ont rejoint
l'application pendant la période on
décidait pour beaucoup de se lancer dans
la livraison qui était une activité
nouvelle et qui a permis à beaucoup de
tenir aussi bien des petits restaurants
indépendants des plus grands des chefs
se sont même lancés dans des activités
de livraison nous avons mis en place
tout un tas d'initiatives pour
améliorer la situation de ces
restaurants pendant une crise majeure la
crise majeure qui sont tous connus que
ça soit réduire nos frais d'activation
couper nos commissions sur les
livraisons en
[Musique]
les commandes à emporter et jouer un
rôle également en offrant des milliers
de repas dans les EHPAD au personnels de
santé donc je dirais c'est la situation
de de l'application de l'application
uber eats aujourd'hui et ce qu'on
observe c'est qu'après cette essor et
cet engouement qui a été entraîné par la
crise du covid les essors perdus et on
continue aujourd'hui d'apporter une
solution aussi bien au coursier aux
travailleurs indépendants aux
utilisateurs qui utilisent nos services
pour gagner du temps pour améliorer leur
quotidien
je vous remercie en effet il y a un
centre de ces données qui sont et je
note que vous avez demandé de ne pas
communiquer officiellement sur les
données chiffrées mais je précise
qu'elles sont là je vais vous parler de
la sous-location de compte encore une
fois c'est en page 5 vous en parlez mais
j'aimerais bien vous interroger un peu
plus en détail
vous parlez d'un système
d'identification en temps réel est-ce
que vous pouvez nous le décrire est-ce
que vous pouvez aussi nous dire combien
vous avez d'individus au sein du Air
France qui travaille sur cette question
des contrôles d'identité de la lutte
contre la sous-location entre ce travail
dissimulé à quelle fréquence et puis
surtout s'il y a eu une évolution de vos
pratiques dans les derniers mois ou les
dernières années notamment suite à
centre de révélation par la presse ou la
justice d'abus oui bien sûr alors si
vous me le permettez je vais passer
quelques minutes sur le sujet de la
fraude au sens large qui est un sujet
que nous prenons évidemment très à cœur
et qui est une priorité depuis
maintenant plusieurs années
globalement la fraude sur la plateforme
ubereat ou sur les plateformes de
livraison peut se manifester de manière
vous avez d'une part ce qu'on appelle la
fraude documentaire qui consiste en fait
à utiliser des faux documents d'identité
pour accéder à l'application et se créer
un compte de livreur c'est un premier
volet de fraude j'expliquerai ce que ce
que nous faisons dans ces cas de figure
et comment nous nous gérons cet aspect
le deuxième aspect auquel vous faites
allusion et ce qu'on appelle la fraude à
la sous-location de compte qui consiste
pour un livreur qui a effectivement un
compte des papiers d'identité de manière
légale sur notre application de louer ce
compte et de permettre à des personnes
qui n'auraient pas pu accéder elle-même
à l'application d'utiliser nos services
sur les deux vecteurs de fraude
depuis plusieurs années maintenant nous
mettons en place tout un tas
d'initiatives pour lutter contre ces
deux phénomènes sur le premier phénomène
qui est la lutte documentaire Le fraude
documentaire pardon nous avons commencer
un audit majeur de notre plateforme au
début de l'année 2022 qui a conduit à la
désactivation de près de 2500 coursiers
sur les 65000 que nous avons audité et
nous avons mis en place à cette occasion
l'utilisation d'une société tierce qui
s'appelle Hubble une société technology
qui est une société approuvée par l'ansy
en France qui désormais valide de
manière vidéo l'ensemble des
candidatures et des papiers d'identité
qui sont fournis par des coursiers qui
veulent s'inscrire sur notre plateforme
donc ça c'est un premier point est-ce
que vous ce que nous avons fait et ce
que nous continuons de faire et les
méthodes je dirais s'améliore la
fiabilité des méthodes s'améliore sur le
volet de la sous-location particulière
et pour en venir plus précisément à
votre question nous avons déployé en
2009 et nous étions les premiers à le
faire une solution de contrôle par
selfie qui en deux mots consiste en tant
que que coursier à recevoir une
notification à des moments aléatoires
qui demandent à un coursier de prendre
une selfie de lui-même ou d'elle-même
qui est comparé automatiquement à une
base ou à la photo qui a été récupérée
lors de cette inscription c'est quelque
chose qu'on nous avons lancé dès 2019 et
je dirais qu'il n'a eu de 16 que de
s'améliorer au fil des années
aujourd'hui on a une fiabilité de nos
modèles qui est très supérieure est-ce
qu'elle pouvait être en 2019 ces
contrôles se font de manière à minima
hebdomadaire qui est d'ailleurs
l'engagement que nous avons donné au
gouvernement lorsque nous avons signé
avec toutes les plateformes une charte
au début de l'année au milieu de l'année
ces contrôles se font donc à minima une
fois par semaine et se font jusqu'à une
fois par jour quand nos systèmes
détectent des signaux faibles ou forts
de fraude potentiel
donc c'est aujourd'hui ce qui est ce qui
est fait pour lutter contre la fraude
vous m'avez demandé le nombre de
personnes qui contribuent à la
vérification de ces documents nous avons
aujourd'hui je crois à peu près 120
personnes on vous la fournit dans les
documents 123 agents qui sont chargés de
la validation des documents d'identité
des contrôles en temps réel qui sont
faits par selfie
merci
c'est intéressant comme réponse parce
que
je crois d'ailleurs que vous le
mentionnez d'autres acteurs visiblement
ne mettent pas en place de contrôle
aléatoire
et utiliser comme explication que
la technologie ou les processus était
encore insuffisant pour le faire
aujourd'hui
tout en restant modeste quant au progrès
que nous devons continuer de faire je
suis à peu près certain que Hubert eats
est un leader en matière de fraude dans
le secteur et je pense que nous sommes
les seuls aujourd'hui à tenir l'ensemble
des engagements qu'on a pu donner au
gouvernements dans la signature de cette
charte ce qui ne veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il n'y ait pas des des progrès
continu à la faire et nous les faisons
mais effectivement je pense que
aujourd'hui nous avons l'ambition il
nous considérons est un leader sur le
domaine illustré par exemple par le fait
d'avoir lancé dès 2019 donc il y a
maintenant près de quatre ans ces
contrôles par selfie sur l'aspect
aléatoire des contrôles c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement important
si le contrôle a lieu chaque jour à la
même heure chaque semaine à la même
heure il devient évidemment plus facile
pour le coursier de
s'arranger de faire et de mettre en
place une fraude de rencontrer une
personne ce qu'on ne voit peut-être pas
dans les chiffres que je vous donne et
dans l'explication je intérêt assez
[Musique]
haute du phénomène ce sont toutes les
micros innovations que nous mettons en
place pour lutter rendre ces contrôles
les plus faibles à titre d'exemple quant
à la fraude documentaire
jusqu'à il y a quelques temps il était
possible on vous demandait effectivement
de duploader sur notre plateforme une
photo de vos documents d'identité cette
photo pouvait être uploadée depuis la
librairie de photos de votre téléphone
un simple changement de dire consistant
à dire on interdit le fait d'opplader
une photo qui existe sur votre téléphone
mais on demande que la photo soit prise
à l'instant T en temps réel ce genre de
choses évidemment sont plein de petites
innovations qui permettent de combattre
l'afrod au maximum ce que nous faisons
par exemple vous parliez de la
sous-location de compte évidemment on
s'assure que si je vois une self une
demande de selfie apparaître en tant que
coursier sur mon téléphone qui me
demande donc de valider mon mon
identité
si on observe que ce coursier
soudainement se déconnecte de son
application sur son téléphone et qu'un
autre téléphone plus loin est utilisé
pour se reconnecter c'est les choses
qu'on est capable de contrôler et qui
déclenche une désactivation immédiate
donc je dirais il y a plein de au-delà
de la réponse générique de l'aspect
selfie que nous avons depuis 2019 les
deux exemples que je viens vous donner
sont des exemples de toutes ces micro
améliorations qui sont faites chaque
semaine chaque mois pour continuer
d'améliorer la fiabilité du système et
réduire au maximum le phénomène de
fraude sur la plateforme est-ce que je
peux vous demander aussi comment vous
sélectionnez le livreur qui va être
choisi pour pouvoir faire une course
est-ce qu'on est juste dans une logique
de distance et de disponibilité est-ce
que c'est un algorithme qui évalue les
livreurs selon leur rapidité ou
fiabilité ou leur historique de de
course alors les les deux grands
paramètres qui sont les plus importants
dans l'expérience qui est d'un livreur
quant à la
[Musique]
il en est même pour la tarification
est-ce que je peux vous demander aussi
vous
vous me précisez que il y a au final une
infime minorité de livreur qui travaille
pour
uber eats à plein temps en tout cas 35
heures par semaine est-ce que vous avez
une évaluation des profils de ces
livreurs de ce que peuvent être leurs
activités complémentaires sont-ils
livreurs sur d'autres plateformes
avez-vous des des statistiques et sinon
quels sont leurs profils professionnels
des étudiants etc alors les informations
que j'ai là-dessus concernant le marché
français en particulier donc 65000
livreurs utilisent l'application
uberides en France
la moyenne d'âge est jeune donc ce sont
des gens qui sont jeunes 25 ans et la
moyenne d'âge sur la plateforme qui est
effectivement utilise la plateforme de
manière complémentaire
avec en moyenne 10 heures d'activités
sur la plateforme par semaine
70% de ses livreurs nous disent avoir un
revenu complémentaire à cela ou une
activité je dirais supplémentaire à cela
et fondamentalement et je crois que vous
l'avez entendu un petit peu de la part
de dracauche rochayeux tout à l'heure
fondamentalement ce qu'on entend
beaucoup des livreurs à qui nous parlons
c'est
deux choses premièrement effectivement
la flexibilité sont des gens qui pour la
majorité ne souhaitent pas être employés
et valorise la flexibilité de se
connecter quand ils le souhaitent mais
deuxièmement ce qu'il faut je pense pas
oublier c'est que c'est une activité qui
est accessible sans diplôme dans lequel
votre prénom ou la couleur de votre peau
ou votre nom de famille ou lors de la
ville dans laquelle vous habitez n'entre
pas en compte et qui permet à des gens
qui pour un tiers étaient au chômage
avant d'avoir ce type d'activité d'avoir
un revenu et d'avoir un revenu décent
avec une volonté de notre part d'avancer
de plus en plus vers plus de protection
sociale et notamment les l'exemple des
accords sociaux qui ont pu être fait
dans mon SIO à parler tout à l'heure sur
lesquels je serai ravi de revenir
toujours sur ces sujets de mon côté
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler des
des mesures que vous prenez sur la
question des accidents évidemment on a
des livreurs parfois tard sous la pluie
est-ce que vous considérez comme
responsable est-ce que vous avez un
engagement prédit livreur pour les
assurer ou les protéger en cas
d'accident oui alors évidemment c'est un
sujet qu'on prend très au sérieux
quand Dara a rejoint l'entreprise en
évidemment il a amené une succession de
changements
quelle est la fait allusion tout à
l'heure l'un d'entre eux était de mettre
la sécurité au cœur de nos priorités
stratégiques donc c'est devenu une des
trois ou quatre priorités stratégiques
de la Société pendant les trois ou
quatre années qui ont suivi son arrivée
c'est depuis devenu l'une de nos valeurs
d'entreprise ce que ça veut dire en
particulier sur le monde de la livraison
deux grands domaines sur lesquels nous
travaillons le premier pan la prévention
des accidents le deuxième pan comment
s'assurer les protections sont les
meilleures si un accident survient pour
les travailleurs et les coursiers sur le
domaine de la protection
de la prévention pardon nous faisons
beaucoup de choses que ça soit s'assurer
par exemple que lorsque les bulletins
météo France indiquent des risques
oranges ou rouges nous ne communiquions
pas d'informations qui incitent les
coursiers à prendre la route et je
dirais au contraire quand c'est des
alertes rouges dans lesquels on
communique en temps réel pour prévenir
nous avons mis en place tout un tas de
partenariats qui visent à amener du
contenu au sein de l'application
uber eats qui peut être consultable par
les coursiers quant à l'équipement à
avoir quant à la meilleure manière de se
conduire sur la route quand tu as des
rappels du code de la route et donc je
dirais nous nous intervenons beaucoup en
termes de prévention nous subventionnons
du matériel de sécurité pour les
coursiers casques gilet réfléchiss qui
leur permettent un accès à des prix à
des tarifs préférentiels ça c'est un des
exemples de ce que nous faisons dans le
domaine de la prévention le deuxième
point important est que se passe-t-il
lorsqu'un accident arrive nous avons mis
en place une couverture
avec AXA et d'ailleurs la France a été
le premier marché sur lequel cette
couverture a été mise en place elle est
depuis étendue à l'ensemble de nos
marchés européens qui permet une
couverture santé et prévoyance pour les
chauffeurs et conducteurs qui sera
victimes et livreur qui serait victime
d'accident elle permet également elle
offre une responsabilité civile qui
couvre les dommages qui pourraient être
causés à des tiers et enfin des
financements en cas d'incapacité de
travail qu'un accident soit survenu lors
de l'application lors de l'utilisation
de l'application
uber eats ou en dehors de cette
plateforme
enfin le dernier sujet peut-être en
termes de sécurité qui je sais est
important également ce sont les
agressions dont ce sont fait écho la
presse dans ces fêtes écho la presse à
certaines occasions les agressions de
coursier notamment la nuit comme vous
l'avez mentionné là-dessus nous avons
signé un partenariat avec une société
qui s'appelle juridica qui permet
d'offrir gratuitement au coursier un
accompagnement juridique qui leur permet
s'il le souhaite de porter plainte et de
prendre les les actions en justice
nécessaires
merci monsieur le président monsieur
je souhaiterais moi vous messieurs vous
poser des questions qui reviennent sur
la période du dérivations
uber-files donc de la période
2014-2016 qui est le l'objet de départ
de notre enquête
parlementaire alors tout d'abord vous
avez vous Monsieur Pierre Dimitri
gorcoty participer à cette rencontre le
premier octobre 2014
avec Monsieur tresse calanic et Elvis
président du groupe David plouf qui
était ancien conseiller de Barack Obama
et
donc vous même
PDG duber pour l'Europe de l'Ouest et
vous avez donc rencontré à ce moment-là
Monsieur Emmanuel Macron ministre de
l'Économie depuis 5 semaines et cette
première rencontre ne figurait pas à
l'agenda du ministre à l'époque
cette rencontre ensuite va être suivie
d'une autre deuxième rendez-vous le 20
janvier 2015 je crois pas que vous
participez à ce deuxième rendez-vous
mais vous me direz là c'était sans doute
un rendez-vous entre monsieur treize
calani et Monsieur Emmanuel Macron on
est en train vous savez de de recouper
l'ensemble des données des uberphales
elles ont d'abord été transmise
aujourd'hui au consortium du journaliste
et
médiatisé par voie de par voie
d'articles et depuis une semaine notre
commission d'enquête parlementaire a pu
avoir par le biais de lanceur d'alerte
un bon nombre de documents qui ne que
nous avons épluché mais qui nécessite
encore beaucoup de travail je vais pas
vous lire tous ces documents mais vous
citez quand même quelques éléments à la
suite du premier rendez-vous
monsieur Marc Magan
envoie un message résumant à ses
collaborateurs en un mot spectaculaire
du jamais vu on quitte Bercy et on file
à l'aéroport je vous tape un rapport
dans la journée beaucoup de boulot à
venir mais on va danser bientôt
deuxième message va dire globalement
l'objectif du ministère de l'Économie et
d'avancer afin de clore le dossier VTC
taxis tout en évitant que trop de
barrières soient imposées au
développement du secteur VTC
et finalement on comprend que
[Musique]
l'enjeu pour uber suite à l'adoption de
la loi tenue c'est d'obtenir
d'autres modifications du cadre
réglementaire et d'ailleurs on va avoir
un message de Maxime druineau Le bises
d'Hubert qui est présent à la deuxième
rencontre de Bercy qui va envoyer un
compte rendu aux avocats d'entrée en
disant Monsieur Manuel Macron est
favorable à une licence light pour les
VTC et par conséquent un allégement
significatif des conditions requises
renforcées par la loi thévenou
et tous ces éléments là on va comprendre
que ça va donner lieu à un deal pour
reprendre le terme même qu'Emmanuel
Macron va utiliser entrée manuel Macron
et très escalanique et Maxime Drino va
même expliquer dans un message le plan
en fait qui était élaboré entre Bercy et
l'équipe du Berre à laquelle vous faites
partie une stratégie en deux temps et
c'est dit comme tel nous nous sommes mis
d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron sur un
process en deux temps un proposer un ou
plusieurs amendements à la Loi Macron
avant de avant demain soir afin de
modifier la réglementation actuelle
introduite par la loi TV nous donc ça il
s'agira des amendements de Monsieur Luc
Bello qui seront transmis clés en main
par l'équipe d'Hubert et on a plein de
messages ou l'équipe d'Hubert dont vous
faisait partie à ce moment-là et vous
fait toujours partie se féliciter qui
soit si bien repris et deuxième temps
nous avons une fenêtre de 4 semaines
pour mener une campagne de communication
avec Macron afin de faire accepter
l'idée qu'une licence VTC Lite serait
une solution pour l'emploi et la
mobilité dans ce contexte elle Gira de
trouver le moment opportun pour rédiger
un décret abolissant le régime proposé
par la loi thévenou et introduit dans
les recommandation plus souple et on
comprend que de toute façon les
amendements d'ailleurs c'est écrit par
la suite les amendements sont rejetés
comme prévu dans la stratégie bon les
amendements portés par Luc Bello vont
peut-être pas mal tendre à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a pas de naïveté sur le
fait que ça serait quand même compliqué
de les obtenir parce que la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et la ligne
majoritaire dans le gouvernement n'est
pas celle d'une manuel Macron mais vont
créer un climat et on dans cette
stratégie là il est anticipé que les
amendements seront rejetés mais bon du
coup permettre à Emmanuel Macron d'être
dans un autre rapport de force pour
pouvoir obtenir une arrêtée qui sera
pris par la suite sur la formation et
qui soit beaucoup plus satisfaisant pour
pour Hubert
je vous donne je vous lis d'autres
extraits c'est quand même une excellente
nouvelle on a trois amendements déposés
par un député socialiste qui porte sur
des éléments clés du régime il a
notamment gardé l'amendement sur les
garésors ceux-ci permet comme le comme
c'était le but d'amorcer le débat sur un
régime VTC assoupli ensuite
on on a d'autres éléments qui nous
montrent et je terminerai là-dessus que
le la formation le décret
qui va faire l'objet de pas mal d'art
lire tour avec la direction du Berre
concernant la formation qu'il a fait
passer de 250 heures à 7 heures
va être considéré par la direction du
Berre comme une comme une victoire en
fin de compte comme une avancée je relis
pas l'intégralité des messages que j'ai
lu à d'autres auditions mais juste des
petits passages
nous venons d'obtenir communication de
l'arrêté examen à première lecture s'est
arrêtée va exactement dans le sens que
nous poussons depuis plusieurs mois par
la suite il est écrit je considère ce
soir que ce texte est une très bonne
avancée pour nous tous même si ce n'est
pas encore un régime pi-topi donc là on
comprend que au moment de la fin du bear
pop qui semble être un horizon
inévitable pour la plateforme Hubert il
faut absolument qu'uber puisse mettre
massivement des VTC sur le marché pour
pouvoir toujours pouvoir exister se
développer et que finalement
les conditions de cette arrêtée qui
rabaissent le montant des heures et
ensuite fait en sorte qu'un examen en
deux épreuves va permettre en une
journée finalement à
Hubert de pouvoir recruter très
rapidement des chauffeurs VTC il y a
d'autres moments d'autres messages ou
votre collègue de l'époque Thibault
saint Phal se félicite vous écrit à vous
il y a d'autres collègues non je ne sais
pas si vous faites partie des
destinataires non il écrit à Alexandre
quintar Craig
et il dit notamment mais clairement
depuis Jean on a pesé lourd donc il y a
vraiment une satisfaction et au point
que Marc Maga n'écrira le 12 janvier
2016 à Emmanuel Macron et dira ayant le
plaisir enfin et dira clairement cela
représente un énorme énormément de
travail de tous les côtés y compris et
surtout de la part du ministère de
l'Économie et nous en sommes sincèrement
reconnaissants est-ce que vous pouvez un
peu préciser vous votre vécu de tout cet
épisode et
aussi quel rôle pouvait jouer Emmanuel
Lacresse qui était à ce moment du
cabinet d'Emmanuel Macron dans tous ce
dossier
est-ce que je peux rajouter juste à tes
questions de de la rapporteur
effectivement c'est c'est un élément
très important
ce qui était intéressant dans l'audition
que l'on vient d'avoir de Monsieur Coop
qui était
pas directement dans votre équipe il
disait justement qu'il était rattaché à
l'époque à la Californie même s'il était
à Paris sur les questions de
communication
il a décrit une une culture au fond
alors en utilisant l'expression soupe un
peu de d'exagération interne dans les
relations
avec à la fois exagération dans le dans
le ton ayant toujours un ton très
dynamique très positif de la part des
employés du beurre dans leur
communication et compris entre eux mais
aussi peut-être une forme de de pression
de la part des opérationnels notamment
des États-Unis sur les équipes de
communication et de lobbying à Paris qui
pouvait expliquer parfois une forme de
d'exagération des résultats ou des
entretiens par exemple avec les pouvoirs
publics est-ce que en plus s'il vous
plaît des réponses à la rapporteur
est-ce que ça vous semble refléter
l'ambiance et la tonalité des échanges
qu'il pouvait y avoir à
uber à l'époque et peut-être d'ailleurs
certaines formulations qu'on peut
retrouver dans les überfils
je vous propose de démarrer avec mes
réponses et puis je laisserai peut-être
en dit également s'exprimer sur les
aspects très liés aux efforts de
lobbying et d'affaires publiques
en ce qui me concerne
la première chose les rencontres avec
Emmanuel Macron qu'elle vous faites
allusion ont eu lieu dans le cadre de
ces fonctions de ministre de l'économie
des finances et du numérique supervisant
à l'époque le secteur des VTC Monsieur
Manuel Macron a toujours été très clair
que le service uberpop selon lui n'avait
pas d'avenir en France et ne s'inscrivez
pas dans le modèle social français et je
voudrais malgré tout rappeler je pense
que vous avez entendu à ce stade de
marque Magan lui-même de Monsieur Valls
monsieur Cazeneuve est beaucoup d'autres
à savoir que dans les années qui ont
suivi l'évolution réglementaire pour ce
qui touche au VTC en France a été dans
tous les sens sauf le sens défendu par
Hubert à savoir un accès à la profession
rendu de plus en plus compliqué et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a conduit la crise des
lotis et près 10 000 chauffeurs se
retrouvant quasiment du jour au
lendemain sans la possibilité d'exercer
leur activité de chauffeur
le l'examen qui a été mis en place
Suisse à suite à cette loi grand
Guillaume avait un taux de succès de 14
%
a été dénoncé par le Conseil d'État qui
lui-même a dit qu'il selon lui ne
permettait pas à des chauffeurs la libre
le libre établissement d'une activité
donc je dirais
je pense qu'il est une paraît assez
clair à ce stade qui a pas eu deal quel
qu'il soit que les résultats n'ont
certainement pas été là d'un point de
vue des messages et des positions que
défendaient Hubert sur l'accès à la
profession
enfin quant aux éléments qui concernent
les propos de marque ou d'autres
d'autres personnes ce sont leurs propos
ce que vous m'avez posé comme question
concernant les messages de Monsieur coop
en deux mots je pense que il résume
assez bien le fait que la société que de
l'époque a été vite sans doute trop vite
comme je l'ai dit dans mon promo
liminaire on teste pas certainement pas
les erreurs qui ont été faites mais ce
sont des erreurs que je et nous
considérons à ce stade être derrière
nous vous l'avez entendu Dara la société
a fondament fondamentalement changé dans
tous les aspects possibles et je suis
sûr qu'en dit pourra nous en dire plus
également sur la manière avec laquelle
aujourd'hui on réfléchit à notre
stratégie d'affaires publiques et plus
généralement et la manière avec laquelle
nous organisons notre notre société
en français merci donc de votre patience
par le truchement des interprètes
permettez-moi tout d'abord de dire que
pendant que je travaillais au sein de
l'équipe des affaires publiques de 2014
j'étais au Royaume-Uni et Monsieur Magan
était mon manager je n'ai pas pris par
différentes réunions je peux pas me
prononcer sur les tenants les
aboutissants terribles mais je pourrais
vous dire ceci
le fait que nous ayons commis des
erreurs durant cette période de nous
dire une nous faisions preuve de trop de
confrontation avec les pouvoirs publics
et nous réagissons à ce que nous
pensions être à l'époque comme une
position très grave et agressive à
Hubert en Europe alors nous ne
dépendons pas les activités de l'époque
mais je dirais que depuis 2017 et en
tout cas depuis que je mène l'équipe de
faire un public depuis 2021 nous tentons
d'être le plus transparent que possible
et ne respectons toutes nos obligations
matières de transparence en vertu de la
loi française et je pense que notre
relation avec les
responsables publics en France ailleurs
ont été très positives les sociétés
démocratiques sont en mesure de
d'adopter des lois qui fonctionnent pour
tous les plans de la société et cette
capacité est grandement améliorée par
des sociétés telles qu'Hubert qui
respectent c'était exprime les souhaits
des chauffeurs et exprime également des
arguments sur l'incidence de ces mesures
sur notre propre activité je dirais que
je m'occupe de politique publique pour
plus de 70 pays dans le monde et lorsque
je vois ce qui se fait dans le Parlement
et je réfléchis aux endroits où les pays
sont les réglementations les plus strict
en matière de mobilité je pense que la
France se trouve très haut dans cette
liste et donc l'idée que nous recevrions
un traitement préférentiel de quelle
façon que ce soit je ne pense pas que
les faits témoignent de cela
alors je vais être franche mais monsieur
Dimitri gorcoti
monsieur Andrew Berne vous ne pouvez pas
à la fois dire les pratiques totalement
illégales scandaleuses d'hier d'Hubert
on les réprouve et aujourd'hui on a fini
avec tout ça
et me dire finalement qui a pas eu deal
et que tout ce que je viens de vous lire
comme message n'ont jamais existé
je n'ai pas inventé ces messages vous ne
niez pas la réalité de ces messages à
moins que vous puissiez me dire que ces
messages n'ont jamais existé qu'ils sont
une construction une falsification de la
part de Monsieur
Marc Magan mais elle n'est pas votre
propos donc ces messages existent bien
et je vous en ai lu que quelques
extraits nous en avons plein nous avons
d'ailleurs y compris les messages une
fois par semaine qui rendent compte de
l'état des relations avec Emmanuel
Macron et de l'état de la discussion sur
le cadre réglementaire et législatif en
France
donc oui il y a bien eu énormément
d'échanges avec le ministre de
l'économie de l'époque des rencontres
physiques des échanges par mail des
échanges par SMS avec une énorme
satisfaction
exprimée dans ces messages par la
direction du maire
sur notamment l'atterrissage concernant
le décret sur la formation qui vous
permettait d'avoir énormément de VTC à
la disposition sur le marché vous pouvez
pas nier cette réalité ce qui est vrai
par contre c'est que ni monsieur Valls
ni monsieur vidaliste ni monsieur
Cazeneuve
qui était opposé au modèle Hubert c'est
pas simplement Albert pop
eux n'étaient pas au courant ils nous
l'ont bien confirmé il n'était pas au
courant de ces échanges et ils ont le
sentiment eux d'avoir participé à une
inter à cheval
négociation interministérielle
sur l'arrêté final indépendamment toute
pression mais dans un contexte bien
particulier
mais sur l'ensemble de ces messages je
vois bien à chaque fois que vous
demandez à des modifications et que vous
êtes à la fin de ces négociations très
satisfaits de ce que vous avez obtenu et
pour cause passer de 250 à 7 heures
pour la formation avec un examen alors
certes dans une situation antérieure où
vous aviez des entreprises de formation
qui
pouvaient aussi totalement
s'extraire du cadre légal mais quand
vous dites d'une aire de confrontation
nous passons à une aire de dialogue j'ai
plutôt l'impression que d'une aire de
confrontation avec la société française
et où votre principal et seul soutien
Emmanuel Macron et un certain nombre de
députés qui étaient minoritaires
vis-à-vis du gouvernement est-ce que
vous êtes pas passé aujourd'hui à une
heure ou pour le coup quand monsieur
Valls monsieur vidalisme monsieur
Cazeneuve était en désaccord avec la
stratégie uber on a un monsieur du soft
une madame borne et un monsieur Beaune
trois ministres qui sont favorables à
ces stratégies est-ce que c'est pas là
le la grande différence en termes de
période puisque à l'époque vous
n'obtenez pas de gain de cause sur les
textes législatives que ce soit la la
loi TV nous la loi grand Guillaume mais
néanmoins vous obtenez sur l'arrêté
concernant la formation du 2 février
2016 et par contre sur l'air actuel et
on l'a vu dans l'audition de Monsieur
kocherai que vous obtenez gain de cause
sur la stratégie dialogue social et
droits sociaux à travers la création de
l'ARPE et à travers le le refus par la
France
de soutenir la directive présomption de
salariat mais vraiment sur ces questions
de tous les éléments que je vous ai
donné factuellement des échanges que
nous que nous disposons
en vue de de peser sur l'arrêté de
février est-ce que les extraits que je
vous ai lu ont bien existé ou pas
je pense qu'il y a plusieurs choses à
dire
la responsabilité du lobby pendant les
périodes vous avez parlés
et je réitère ce que nous avons dit oui
lorsque nous avons vu le cadre éclair
régulératoire en France
uber n'a pas été favorisé sous aucune
forme pour répondre à vos commentaires
par rapport à la directive et les
commentaires de notre PDG je peux être
encore plus clair que Dara Hubert et
évidemment tout à fait concerné et
inquiet quand au résultat de sa
directive
Dara et moi-même avons rencontré des
commissaires deux fois ces dernières
années
notre représentation est présente quant
à sa directive il nous croyons toujours
que nous partageons toujours certains
des objectifs de cette de la Commission
européenne il y a une opportunité de
créer une directive qui
fournit à la fois de la sécurité et de
la flexibilité c'est une bonne occasion
il y a plusieurs problèmes
par rapport à cette directive sous la
forme présente la première par exemple
c'est que nous pensons qu'il y a une
opportunité qui a été manquée d'être
plus précis dans les critères qui
apparaissent actuellement dans ces
directives
tout particulièrement quand à l'idée du
contrôle ou de la subordination qui est
au cœur
de la manière dont nous pensons à un
employé ou alors un sous-traitant cela
n'a pas été suffisamment expliqué sur la
directive les critères ne sont pas
clairs donc c'est une occasion
d'être plus précis de fournir au
travailleur au syndicat et aux
entreprises comme uber
un conseil bien plus précis sur la
manière dont ils doivent appliquer leurs
différents modèles ensuite
vous avez fait référence au dialogue
social en français ailleurs
uber a changé sa relation avec les
syndicats ces dernières années nous
avons signé un accord international avec
la Fédération de transparence nous avons
également des accords avec le
Royaume-Uni avec la Belgique avec la
France et avec l'Italie
tout cela avant cette directive sur le
travail des plateformes donc nous ne
devons pas être pénalisés
pour le fait de travailler avec des
syndicats du monde entier
cela ne devrait pas être retenu contre
uber nous avons été tout à fait
transparent sur les problèmes que nous
voyons avec cette directive nous sommes
engagés effectivement avec les
ministères en France le ministère des
Transports du travail
entre autres et je pense que vous l'avez
entendu ce matin de la part du ministère
du Travail nous n'avons pas eu de
conversation directe avec eux mais il y
a une des conversations il y a eu un
échange donc les processus de l'obéine
que nous mettons en place aujourd'hui et
tout à fait transparent
on ne dit rien en privé que l'on ne
dirait pas en public
d'un point de vue historique je
reconnais tout à fait que les emails et
les correspondances dont vous avez parlé
de rendre donnant un tableau sombre
malheureusement
c'est
Magan qui a répondu
à la manière dont il a entretenu une
relation avec la cabinet de Monsieur
Macron
alors vous ne pouvez pas
réduire l'ensemble de ces échanges à une
implication uniquement de marque Magan à
son titre personnel d'abord parce que
Monsieur Marc Magan agissait dans Hubert
avec les responsabilités que
l'entreprise lui imputait et parce que
il y a d'autres échanges qui impliquent
Thibault Saint Phalle qui implique
Monsieur Pierre Dimitri gorgotti et tous
ces messages la commission d'enquête
parlementaire y accède dorénavant et et
à moins que vous puissiez et je vous
rappelle que vous parlez sous serment et
que bien sûr il n'y ait pas question de
commettre de parjure nous avons ces
documents là donc soit vous attestez de
la véracité de ces documents soit vous
estimez ces documents sont faux mais
nous nous avons des documents qui
montrent bien l'ensemble des
négociations qu'il y a pu y avoir et le
degré aussi de satisfaction qu'il
pouvait y avoir pour Hubert d'obtenir
cet accord ce deal des mots le terme dit
les et dit par le ministre de l'Économie
lui-même à l'époque concernant cette
arrêtée
je
j'entends et c'est important que la
commission d'enquête parlementaire
entendent par ailleurs de votre part que
vous désavouez les pratiques agressives
de lobbying de la de l'époque parce que
je rappelle que les pratiques de
lobbying de l'époque révélée par Les
hubert-féles était de plusieurs natures
puisqu'il y avait à la fois évidemment
beaucoup de moyens et j'aimerais bien
avoir vos éléments sur les moyens
alloués au cabinet de conseil très
nombreux pour à la fois faire un travail
de repérage de l'ensemble des décideurs
publics à avec lesquels rentrer en
relation que ce soit pour pouvoir
organiser des rencontres
officielles ou officieuses mais il y
avait aussi un lobbying qui visait à
commander des enquêtes d'économistes
dont les conclusions étaient déjà fixées
dans le bon de commande nous avons
auditionné une partie de ces économistes
il y avait également des articles qui
étaient payés pour vanter le modèle uber
et vanter son ses conséquences en termes
de création d'emplois alors que des
études indépendantes d'économistes et de
sociologue aujourd'hui attestent que
pour la plupart notamment dans les
chauffeurs VTC il s'agit de personnes en
emploi qui vont basculer et faire le
choix de basculer VTC il y a eu aussi un
lobbying agressif qui visait à notamment
organiser le une stratégie du chaos pour
reprendre le terme même de Travis
scannatique
et notamment dans le cas des conflits
taxi VTC et qui pouvait aller jusqu'à
payer des chauffeurs VTC pour qu'ils
participent à des manifestations
j'oublie encore certainement des
éléments oui il y avait aussi la
stratégie du Berre de recruter parmi des
décideurs publics il en a été ainsi du
recrutement de Nelly Cruz de David plouf
ou de Grégoire COP pour pouvoir
développer aussi au sein duber un réseau
influent au niveau du coeur des
appareils d'État de différents États
membres pour le développement du maire
donc tous ces stratégies là est
extrêmement était une stratégie de lobby
extrêmement agressif qui par ailleurs a
lieu avant la loi Sapin 2 donc
pour la plupart on ne peut pas regarder
ça d'un point de vue légal pour certains
aspects il me semble mais bon et dès le
début en fait une stratégie du Berre
très conscient de l'illégalité et qui
justement assumait d'être dans une
stratégie d'imposer un état de fait à
l'état de droit on a même là un document
pyramide of sheets donc désolé pour la
commission d'enquête parlementaire
d'utiliser un terme grossier mais enfin
bref la pyramide de merde et qui était
extrait d'une présentation à destination
des cas du berne en Europe qui était
datées de 11 décembre 2014 et qui montre
bien comment en fait la stratégie assume
en fait de devoir être amené à des
procès des conducteurs à des enquêtes
réglementaires à des procédures à
administratives à des litiges et quand
on voit que
Hubert était jusqu'à était même prêt y
compris avec le kinchift à anticiper ça
fait tellement son illégalité qu'ils
étaient pré-anticiper s'il y avait une
descente de la DGCCRF ou d'autres
instances de contrôle il y avait un
logiciel interne qui permettait de
supprimer toutes les données donc est-ce
que toutes ces pratiques-là que j'ai
citées vous n'en avez plus qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui
oui et d'ailleurs vous déposez la
question mais juste pour répondre
vraiment précisément par exemple sur le
kill switch qui a fait l'objet de
révélation est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer aujourd'hui que ce logiciel
n'existe plus et n'est plus utilisé en
plus des questions de la rapporteur
naturellement
je veux commencer peut-être par le kill
switch et puis je laisserai en dit
parler de tous les aspects lobbying vous
avez soulevé madame leur rapporteur en
ce qui concerne le kill switch je peux
vous confirmer que aujourd'hui et ce
depuis l'arrivée de notre CIO
d'aracochrogène dans l'entreprise la
société n'a pas de logiciel qu'il switch
qui soit dédié à contrecarrer des
activités des activités réglementaires
donc ça je peux vous le dire de manière
très ferme comme je pense beaucoup de
groupes ou beaucoup de sociétés il
existe des logiciels qui permettent en
cas de vol ou perte d'un appareil de
bloqué le l'ordinateur ou le téléphone
d'un employé mais à nouveau c'est
dispositifs ne sont jamais utilisés pour
contrecarrer des actions réglementaires
et je dirais bien au contraire
le groupe Hubert au sens large collabore
de manière très fréquente avec les
autorités dans plein de pays pour
participer à des enquêtes ou aider de la
manière qu'on qu'on puisse des
des procédures donc voilà pour ce qui
est du kit switch
la présence de ces communications
l'existence de ces communications c'est
arrivé effectivement durant la période
dont nous avons parlé ce que je dirais
personnel c'est que j'étais je suis
membre de l'entreprise depuis 2014
donc cela fait partie de la période des
événements dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
et je vais être totalement franc il n'y
a rien que j'ai pu faire qui
compromettrait mon intégrité personnelle
durant ces démarches de lobbying les
les activités que vous avez décrites
en fait on ne sait pas si ces activités
ont vraiment eu lieu ou s'il y a juste
des messages à leur sujet les
représentants officiels
quand
il s'agissait de le fait de payer pour
une étude et tout à fait inaccessible
nous le faisons pas aujourd'hui
et si je peux être totalement honnête
aucune de ces choses n'arrivent
aujourd'hui
nous soutenons plus de transparence dans
notre activité de lobbying nous voulons
avancer pour être de plus en plus
transparent pour les entreprises de uber
mais aussi d'autres pour que tous les
entreprises impliquées dans des
activités de lobbying
respecte les mêmes règles et nous nous
avons voulu changer cette culture
d'entreprise cela fait 9 ans que je
travaille chez Hubert et Pierre sera
sûrement d'accord avec moi la culture
art réellement changé
la manière dont aujourd'hui nous
entretons nos relations avec les
représentants publics la manière de nous
dialoguons avec les coursiers les
chauffeurs
et tout à fait différent aujourd'hui
maintenant je pense qu'on peut être très
clair se passer tout à fait inacceptable
mais depuis 2017 toutes ces activités
comme le kill switch que Pierre a
mentionné non plus lieu
alors aussi si je peux permettre quand
même parce que je veux je veux pas qu'il
y a de perte dans la traduction
parce que certaines des activités que
vous venez de dénoncer comme il
acceptable surtout même il me semble
aujourd'hui toujours pratique courante
en France comme aux États-Unis comme
comme dans notre pays européen quand
elles sont dans un cadre légal donc je
suis quand même vous demander de
préciser votre pensée quand vous dites
qu'embauchez des officiels publics et
inacceptables
c'est légal en France comme bailleurs
quand ça se fait dans le cadre de la
réglementation des conflits d'intérêts
et
des passages entre le public et le privé
que la même façon que payer pour des
passages médias assez centré sur devant
le cadre de contrats avec des agences de
communication ou de relation publique
qui peuvent vous donner accès à à des
médias se fait donc je vais juste vous
inviter quand même un peu à clarifier
parce que si vous considérez aujourd'hui
si vous nous dites sincèrement cuber
n'embauche jamais des gens qui ont pu
travailler dans le public pour avoir
vécu aux Etats-Unis assez longtemps je
pense que c'est une pratique assez
courante de la dans le secteur privé et
de la même façon que le secteur public a
tendance à faire venir des gens qui
viennent du secteur privé donc je vais
peut-être vous inviter à préciser un peu
votre pensée sur la façon dont vous avez
formulé tout ça
dans la loi et dans les processions de
conflit d'intérêt ça existe
effectivement dans tous les pays où nous
travaillons je pense qu'il est
effectivement des questions est-ce que
voilà ça a été ça se passait dans le
passé dans ce contexte légal
je vous en prie
président bonjour messieurs
voilà je voulais vous interroger sur une
phrase que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
vous avez dit on nous on ne vérifie pas
c'est à propos de la délivreur
effectivement que vous embauchez enfin
que vous embauchez lapsus qui sont sur
la plateforme vous dites on ne prend pas
en compte la personne ni sa couleur donc
moi j'ai deux questions est-ce que vous
regardez le casier judiciaire parce
qu'elle a on a pu se rendre compte
quelquefois que des personnes qui
livraient et profiter donc des
livraisons
uber faisait aussi du trafic de
stupéfiant c'est arrivé donc est-ce que
ça vous le vérifiez est-ce qu'il y a
moyen de vérifier est-ce que vous le
vérifierez à l'avenir et d'autre part
quand vous dites on ne vérifie pas aussi
la couleur ou l'origine en tout cas tout
ce qui a trait à la personne ça veut
dire aussi qu'il y a forcément des
personnes en situation irrégulière qui
travaillent
voilà
je vais répondre à ces questions juste
pour clarifier mon propos parce que je
vais être sûr qu'il est pas été mal
compris tout à l'heure
mon point était de dire que le type
d'opportunité de travail que des
plateformes comme uber eats offrent à
des travailleurs sont des opportunités
qui sont qui ne font pas qui n'incluent
pas les nombreuses discriminations que
malheureusement existe dans nos sociétés
dans les environnements dans lequel on
vit tous et c'est ça que je souhaitais
dire quand je disais quel que soit vos
origines votre couleur ce que peu
importe vous avez le même accès à
l'application maintenant sur les deux
questions que vous avez soulevées en
particulier
la première ou peut-être la première qui
touchait au
casier judiciaire
alors il y a deux choses là dessus
premièrement sur l'activité de chauffeur
VTC
l'obtention de la carte professionnelle
de chauffeur VTC et conditionnel à un
casier judiciaire qui soit vierge et
donc dans ce cas de figure là ou dans ce
cadre-là nous ne verrons pas nous-mêmes
les casiers judiciaires mais nous
vérifions l'authenticité de la carte
professionnelle qui par conclusion par
déduction justifie du casier vierge en
ce qui concerne l'activité de livraison
uber eats nous n'avons pas le droit de
demander une copie du casier judiciaire
ce qui signifie que ce n'est pas quelque
chose que nous vérifions lors de
l'inscription
nous prenons évidemment très au sérieux
tout ce qui touche à la sécurité aussi
bien la sécurité des utilisateurs de
l'application que celles des chauffeurs
coursiers qui utilisent l'application ce
qui signifie que nous sommes en mesure
de d'avoir des retours
terrains qui sont faites d'une partie ou
d'un autre voire même d'un restaurant
nous prenons évidemment très au sérieux
pour s'assurer que la plateforme soit la
plus sûre possible pour toutes les
personnes qui qui l'utilisent
sur le deuxième point
qui était la situation irrégulière c'est
ça oui alors là dessus comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure nous
vérifions systématiquement les permis de
travail donc une carte d'identité les
documents qui autorisent un coursier une
coursier à travailler sur le territoire
français et la société tierce que nous
utilisons pour les contrôles des
documents et notamment pour la contrôle
de véracité des documents Hubble est
évidemment
en mesure de et accorder avec nous sur
les documents qui sont valides et qui
peuvent justifier d'une autorisation de
travailler sur le territoire français
donc je dirais aucun coursier
ne peut de manière légitime
passer
s'inscrire sur la plateforme sans
présenter des documents qui justifient
l'autorisation de travailler et nous
faisons le maximum de l'autre côté pour
nous assurer que les documents qui
effectivement nous sont montrés sont des
documents valides
et authentique
alors j'ai une question très très rapide
une un tout petit peu moins
quel était quels étaient les noms du
cabinet d'Emmanuel Macron avec lesquels
vous étiez en contact pendant toute
cette période là voilà donc j'aimerais
bien connaître les noms deuxième
question je vais revenir sur la
directive présomption
salariat qui se discute à l'échelle
européenne
vous avez dit qu'il faudrait être plus
précis sur les critères de la directive
ce qui est d'ailleurs ce qui a pu dire
aussi madame la Première ministre
Elisabeth borne qu'il fallait augmenter
le nombre de critères être plus précis
bon mais est-ce que ça signifie faire en
sorte de ne pas requalifier vos
chauffeurs en salariés
alors même que l'ensemble des décisions
de justice montre qu'ils sont dans un
rapport de subordination c'est la raison
même d'ailleurs pour laquelle
l'Union européenne est dans cette
agenda législatif est d'ailleurs dans
son étude d'impact
l'Union européenne a estimé à 5 millions
le nombre de travailleurs qui devaient
être qualifiés et en montrant que
c'était surtout d'ailleurs les
chauffeurs VTC et livreur pour lequel
finalement on était plutôt sur des faux
indépendants et vraiment un lien de de
subordination donc finalement est-ce que
vouloir plus de critères
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas cela ne rien
changer à votre relation de
subordination au contrôle que vous
exercez sur eux sans pour autant assumer
les obligations d'employeur
contrairement en fait à tous les
employeurs de ce pays qui qui eux sont
dans des rapports de subordination et
doivent bien assumer les obligations
d'employeur les cotisations sociales
participent aux cotisations retraite le
droit du travail
on déconnecte pas on est obligé d'avoir
des entretiens préalables de
licenciement enfin tout ce cadre là donc
voilà précisez bien votre position visée
de cette directive présente son salariat
le fait de vouloir plus de critères
est-ce que finalement c'est pas pour
échapper à toute qualification
de salariés juste sur la première
question pour éviter toute forme de
détournement à des fins de politique
intérieure actuelle est-ce que à ce
moment là je peux vous demander les noms
des ministres secrétaire d'État et
membres de tous les cabinets avec
lesquels vous étiez en contact à cette
époque
malheureusement je n'ai pas les
informations relatives à toutes les
réunions que l'équipe des petits publics
organisé mais nous pourrions fournir ces
éléments par écrit à l'issue de la rue
nous avons dans le cadre des obligations
transparence des rapports la matière en
France malheureusement je suis donc en
Californie donc je n'ai pas cette
information disponible aujourd'hui c'est
le temps de votre question liée
directive de lieu sur les la plateforme
alors nous pensons
honnêtement qu'il est c'est l'occasion
d'établir une distinction entre les faux
emplois il faut salariés et
et les vrais indépendants et nous
pensons que l'Institut du côté des vrais
indépendants parce que les on suffit à
ce que nous disent les chauffeurs et les
cours si c'est ce qu'ils soient ils
veulent et aussi parce que nous avons
vraiment
à changer notre modèle depuis ces
dernières années
le modèle de 2017 est très du modèle
d'aujourd'hui nous avons pris beaucoup
de mesures pour préciser notre modèle
qui donne plus de contrôle au coursier
et au chauffeur quant à la manière
d'utiliser la plateforme et l'appli pour
qu'ils aient plus d'informations en
amont nous avons en France un système
qui fournit des informations sur la
quantité de recettes partout et toute
cette formation fournie en amont ce qui
était pas le cas cela permet de préciser
les choses et donner plus de contrôle à
ces particules comme
travailleur
indépendant il s'agissant des critères
précis
de cette relation
le contrôle nous pensons que des mesures
peuvent être prises pour
rendre pour préciser davantage ces
concepts juridiques pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui le Parlement et en Europe
il y a un Majorique très pointillis à ce
sujet et comme l'a dit d'arabe
franchement dans ses réponses nous
constatons que
nous voyons que les tribunaux en France
constataient différentes choses selon
les faits particuliers à certains
personnes et donc bien sûr nous
souhaitons plus de précisions et de
clarté juridique s'agissant des attentes
à l'égard d'une plateforme telle que
notre donc nous continuons de dire c'est
à la commission Parlement et nous
continuerons d'exprimer ce message dans
le cadre des débats sur notre plateforme
mais nous croyons fermement que le
dialogue social du type que doit nous
jouer sont en France fait partie
intégrante de ce processus fut là fait
longtemps que nous parlons de la facer
façon plutôt de donner une vraie voix au
coursier qui travaille dans ce genre de
secteur et nous sommes conscients
le risque d'une société de technologie
domiciliation PRESCO qui parle le passé
était très éloigné de la réalité des
coursiers des chauffeurs pour améliorer
leur vie au quotidien nous pensons que
le dialogue social doit faire partie
intégrante de la solution en France et
en Europe une solution qui permet de
donner une vraie voix au chapitre des
coursiers et des chauffeurs quand elle
administration de ces plateformes et
nous pensons que le dialogue social a
vraiment progressé ces 12 derniers mois
en France nous avons signé deux accords
et nous pensons que c'est une étape
importante et nous pensons également
qu'il reste encore énormément de place
sur la planche que nous pour que nous
continuions d'améliorer la voix de ses
coursiers chauffeurs quotidiens il fera
poursuivre ce dialogue social et nous
espérons signer davantage d'accord
alors je repose ma question à Monsieur
Pierre Dimitri ortoti on est en
commission d'enquête parlementaire
d'accord c'est une commission d'enquête
parlementaire donc ça veut dire que nous
sommes les représentants de la soirée
nationale et nous avons à enquêter sur
le scandale des uber-files dans les
révélations
du consortium du journaliste il y a plus
d'une quarantaine d'échanges dont 17
significations entre le ministre de
l'économie de l'époque et les dirigeants
du Berre est-ce que Monsieur Dimitri
gorcoty vous qui était en fonction dans
cette période là
est-ce que les dirigeants du père
étaient plus en contact pour faire
l'intermédiaire avec Emmanuel Macron à
l'intérieur de son cabinet avec Monsieur
colère avec Monsieur Lacresse avec
madame Julie Bonamy ou avec d'autres
personnes ma question est donc précise
et je demande des réponses précises et
ensuite pour rebondir monsieur Andrew
Berne concernant
toujours la directive présentation de
salariat vous êtes donc en désaccord
avec la Commission européenne qui comme
elle l'indique dans son étude d'impact
considère les chauffeurs uber comme
devant être requalifié en salarié on
peut conclure cela
ce qui va droit
alors je peux je peux démarrer
donc je vais vous dire ce dont je me
rappelle avec le
la mention avant cela du fait que son
effet qui remonte à quasiment 10 ans je
prends justement très au sérieux le rôle
que je joue ici devant cette commission
après avoir prêté serment et j'ai
évidemment pas envie de vous donner une
réponse qui ne soit pas correcte ou
complète et je serais ravi de évidemment
de fouiller mes archives pour vous faire
un retour plus complet maintenant ce
dont je me souviens plusieurs choses
donc j'ai participé à
deux ou trois rendez-vous avec Emmanuel
Macron dans le cadre de ses fonctions en
tant que ministère ministre de
l'économie et des finances et du
numérique à l'époque je me souviens
avoir rencontré
Julie Bonamy
je pense avoir rencontré Alexis Kohler
je l'ai rencontré à minima beaucoup plus
tard dans le cadre de l'Initiative take
for good dans laquelle Hubert jouait un
rôle sur le futur du travail en
partenariat avec la RATP
et il me semble avoir rencontré Monsieur
Lacresse à l'époque donc les noms que
vous avez cité c'est non là en tout cas
me sont familiers je pense avoir
participé à des rendez-vous il se
trouvaient je pourrais pas vous le
certifier premièrement tout de suite
comme ça et deuxièmement je ne pourrai
pas vous dire combien de fois mais je
suis tout à fait prêt à m'engager à
fouiller mes archives et faire une
réponse à la commission si vous le
souhaitez
et je voudrais poursuivre là-dessus
quand je vois par exemple
des SMS de Monsieur ou des échanges
pardon que vous avez monsieur calanic
vous l'encourager à envoyer un SMS à
Monsieur Macron il répond qu'il trouve
que Monsieur Macron est note faire pas
juste trop dur avec avec Hubert est-ce
que vous avez eu le sentiment dans les
relations avec les pouvoirs publics
au-delà des positions qui étaient
exprimées publiquement par les uns et
les autres et Emmanuel Macron étant
clairement en faveur de l'innovation et
plutôt ouvert à l'arrivée d'acteurs de
la tech
monsieur Cazeneuve qui me l'a dit ils
ont intérieur
protecteur de l'ordre public et
peut-être aussi de la régulation liée au
taxi est-ce que vous avez eu le le
sentiment que vous avez joué les uns
contre les autres qu'il y avait des
positions qui ont pu mener à des formes
d'action différentes de la part du
gouvernement des législations ou des
initiatives isolées individuelles
opaque de la part du gouvernement ou que
vous parliez à un seul interlocuteur qui
était le gouvernement français avec sa
diversité les transports l'économie
l'intérieur etc et est-ce que je peux
vous demander à ce moment-là si vous
avez aussi eu des échanges voire
régulier avec le mystère des transports
le mystère de l'Intérieur éventuellement
Matignon et l'Élysée à la fois au niveau
des ministres Premier ministre et de
membres de leur cabinet
je vais démarrer et puis peut-être qu'on
dit pour apporter également sa
perspective
premièrement pour le rappeler les
activités d'affaires publiques ne
rentrez pas dans le périmètre de mes
fonctions quotidiennes je crois monsieur
Coop vous l'a dit plutôt
j'ai été amené à intervenir de manière
ponctuelle en accompagnant certains nos
dirigeants notamment Travis calanic dans
certaines de ces rencontres ce qui
explique
sans doute en tout cas justifie le fait
que je n'ai pas en tête l'ensemble des
rencontres qui puent qui a pu avoir lieu
même ne pas nécessairement me souvenir
moi-même de qui j'ai rencontré
à cette occasion ce que je peux vous
dire en revanche avec ma casquette
opérationnelle à l'époque et que
le message principal que nous cherchions
à porter d'un point de vue à faire
public était de faire remonter ce que
nous observions sur le terrain chaque
jour à savoir que énormément de
candidats chauffeurs de personnes au
chômage frapper à nos portes en nous
disant tiens Hubert comment ça marche
comment je deviens chauffeur et que 99%
de ces gens-là repartaient chez eux
comme ils étaient venus parce que la
réponse était qu'il fallait des mois de
formation qu'il fallait payer des
milliers d'euros qu'il fallait trouver
une voiture qui fallait apprendre les
langues l'histoire française ainsi de
suite donc je dirais on se faisait
l'avocat d'un cadre réglementaire très
strict qui selon nous n'était pas en
adéquation avec les besoins de mobilité
qu'on observait à l'époque qu'on observe
encore aujourd'hui dans une grande
mesure notamment aussi en comparant au
succès qu'on pouvait voir en tout cas
l'essor qu'on pouvait voir dans
différents marchés à travers le monde
donc je dirais l'ensemble de nos
messages en tout cas sur les premières
années auxquelles vous faites référence
était plutôt orienté sur cet accès à la
profession c'est ça ce qu'on cherchait à
défendre sur l'aspect plus particulier
de qui était nos interlocuteurs au
gouvernement il y avait-il un jeu des
ministères les uns envers les autres
je n'ai pas eu le sentiment mais je
pense que enfin ces sujets étaient
plutôt du ressort de Marc Magan donc
j'ai pas nécessairement d'avis très
prononcé là-dessus et je suis sûr qu'en
dit peut apporter ses lumières
merci Pierre alors je pense
qu'avec tout le respect que je dois
dire que
la grande la grande partie des échanges
que Hubert II responsables français
c'est avec le commissaire des transports
je peux pas prononcer sur les autres
noms qui ont été mentionnés mais je
dirais que c'est vraiment cela vaut pour
la période durant laquelle nous avons
commencé à travailler en France c'était
vraiment un long une relation avec le
mystère des transports en raison des
changements en matière de besoin de
mobilité mais je ne puis me prononcer
quant aux tenant les aboutissants des
différents de la relation entre les
différents ministères
alors
voulez-vous que je reparle de nouveau de
la plateforme la directive européenne
sur les plateformes c'est cela peut vous
aider encore une fois il est très
difficile de se prononcer sur
l'argumentation qui est en cours
d'élaboration
il est fort probable que la directive en
l'état continuera d'évoluer d'ici les
6 ou 8 prochains mois mais je puis vous
dire ça c'est nous ne pensons pas que
les
chauffeurs et les coursiers du berceau
sont des employés mais
la manière dont on mène
des activités bon pour être
à ce sujet dans le bon nombre de pays
d'Europe Hubert travaille sur différents
types de marché donc le modèle uber
s'adapte selon les circonstances
juridiques et les précédents juridiques
existence donc si l'on voit par exemple
l'Allemagne
l'écran de majorité des conducteurs
ubers sont des employés et donc le notre
business est en mesure de s'adapter
d'assurer une certaine rentabilité de
manière importante mais pensons que
cela donne une expérience
moins intéressante pour les travailleurs
les coursiers les chauffeurs si on sort
des des villes etc
on peut donner moins d'accès
aux salariés que on peut la base
indépendante il faut avoir comment
évolue le marché pour voir si on doit
changer notre business model pour
respecter la réglementation mais en tout
cas nous respecterons la loi et la
directive telle que mise en œuvre par
les pays d'Europe
merci j'ai une dernière question
Monsieur Pierre Dimitri gorcoty
le 2 avril 2015 est-ce que c'est vous
qui déclenchez le kill switch ou pas et
si c'est pas vous qui est-ce
que c'est vous qui déclenchez le kill
switch asap
alors
j'ai pas souvenir exact
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
ces initiatives et ces logicielles
n'auraient jamais dû être utilisé comme
ça y compris en France
je sais et je pense que vous avez vu
dans les uber five ou par voie de presse
que nous ne n'y ont pas l'utilisation du
kill switch en France notamment dans le
cadre d'une enquête de la DGCCRF
je crois me souvenir d'email de la part
de ZAC de Kevin qui était le directeur
légal à l'époque ordonnant de lancer
cette procédure ce que je peux vous dire
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne et ce
qui touche à mes souvenirs c'est que
d'une part quand les bureaux du Air
France ont été percollectionnés en 2015
mon ordinateur
a été lu mon mot de passe a été donné
aux enquêteurs qui ont pu accéder à mes
données qui d'ailleurs évidemment été
utilisé dans le cadre de la procédure en
cours donc je ne pense pas moi-même
avoir fait une obstruction quelle
qu'elle soit à la
[Musique]
valeur il a suivi les recommandations du
procureur général américain ancien
procureur général américain Eric Holder
a refondu une partie de l'équipe
dirigeante de la société a fait venir un
nouveau set d'administrateur de la
société y compris un président du
conseil d'administration et a mis en
place des procédures internes
d'éthique et de conformité parmi les
plus strictes en ligne avec ce que l'on
doit d'attendre d'une société côté qui
pesait une société cotée qui a un impact
sur la vie tellement de personnes
à travers le monde donc je considère que
la société a fondamentalement changé 90%
les employés n'étaient pas là à l'époque
et en ce qui me concerne personnellement
puisque votre question était personnelle
je suis fier de pouvoir jouer un rôle et
d'avoir pu jouer un rôle dans le
redressement de la société ayant été là
au début et ont vu effectivement les
les les
soucis et les erreurs du passé
je suis fier du chemin parcouru je suis
fier de ce que nous mettons aujourd'hui
en place et de l'aspect pionnier que
nous avons sur le secteur quant à la
protection sociale quant à ce que nous
faisons en matière de fraude et de
sécurité et je reconnais tout à fait
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir et nous y sommes pleinement
engagés
dernière question plutôt réaction
lors de toute cette audition vous nous
avez assuré que les pratiques du berdier
n'étaient pas poursuivi et que vous les
approprié
vous avez vanté le développement du
Berre en présentant quasiment la
plateforme comme une entreprise
philanthropique
mais une question extrêmement précise
Monsieur Pierre Dimitri gorcoty est-ce
que vous avez ou non était responsable
d'un envoi de mail qui met en place le
kill switch
vous n'avez pas été en capacité de
répondre comme si vous vous en souvenez
plus alors que nous avons des documents
qui au contraire latent par conséquent
je n'ai plus aucune question à vous
poser
ce que je peux dire à ça et je vous vois
regarder vos documents et téléphone donc
je suppose que je suis l'auteur de des
messages auxquels vous faites réflexion
je suis bonne foi quand je dis
effectivement ne pas me nécessairement
me rendre compte de quel email j'ai
envoyé quand et de manière plus
importante je prends très au sérieux le
rôle que je viens jouer ici j'ai prêté
serment j'ai tout simplement pas envie
de porter une réponse positive ou
négative à quelque chose qui n'est pas
dont je n'ai pas la certitude je pense
avoir été honnête en vous disant que je
suis effectivement conscient que ces
procédures ont été utilisées je suis
effectivement conscient qu'elles ont été
utilisées en France on ne s'en est pas
caché donc je ne suis pas du tout en
train de me défausser de mes
responsabilités je n'ai plus souvenir de
quel email j'ai envoyé moi-même et c'est
pour ça que je n'ai pas souhaité
confirmer se dire mais évidemment je ne
prétends pas qu'il y ait des faux dans
les uber fail et si c'est ce que vous
voyez dans les traces d'email je serai
ravi de le reconnaître
merci Monsieur
cocotier monsieur barren nous aurons
peut-être du coup des questions
complémentaires peut-être demande de
documents des précisions sur un stand de
ces sujets notamment en réaction au
document que nous a transmis récemment
monsieur Marc Magan avec les échanges
d'e-mails ou de SMS mais dans
l'intervalle je vous remercie de vous
être rendu disponible pour notre
commission d'enquête je vais suspendre
notre séance maintenant et je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée merci